this one's at a difficult time where
he's come from and needs considerable
attention and that's what we do best
here in both houses would you like to
meet him he's perfect
after the first person they still not
too got a special touch a
[Music]
I'll become a little time we're gonna
after him for me won't you you really in
charge out in the elephant I my dad's
away to war
[Music]
Sasa hello who are you
I'm Tom what's hopper first clothes
today son you've got no business being
today
off you go I have to follow orders
kiss the animals escaped during the
bombings stay away from me impostor I
have to get him worried tonight for
booster I had to be my brother I'm not
great in the dark
[Music]
much better than I expected he's an
elephant Pete
[Music]
busted
that's an elephant animals do not vanish
from my zoo
everybody will be looking for buster
they find out Allison they'll destroy
this is worse looking for an elephantine
that's punished what we started
you made me part of something very
special
something I'll never forget
[Music]
you